[Musik]
live aus köln der presseclub mit jörg
schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind an diesem sonntagmittag wir alle
stehen vermutlich in diesem winter vor
der härtesten bewährungsprobe in der
geschichte der republik wir als
gesellschaft die politik die
bundesregierung durch den russischen
angriffskrieg ist unsere sicherheit
längst bedroht aber er frisst sich
zunehmend auch in unserem wohlstand
hinein bei jedem einkauf bei jeder
rechnung sehen wir die höheren preise
bei energie vor allem bei gas sind sie
explodiert bei alldem verliert man
langsam so ein bisschen den überblick
die regierung hat schon allerlei
entlastungen beschlossen immer neue
werden angekündigt aber es gibt
gelegentlich auch ein vor und zurück wie
bei der gasanlage diese woche zunächst
werden zweieinhalb cent mehr kosten
angekündigt dann wird die mehrwertsteuer
gesenkt um das wieder auszugleichen
und was in dem dritten entlastungspaket
drin steckt das täglich neu angekündigt
wird wüssten viele betroffene langsam
gern um für den herbst die rechnung
aufzumachen unser presseclub heute immer
neue entlastungen echte hilfe oder
leeres versprechen und ich freue mich
auf die diskussion mit diesen gästen
peter stefan herbst das wieder bei uns
chefredakteur der saarbrücker zeitung
herzlich willkommen ich freue mich auf
sebastian puschner er ist ressortleiter
politik und stellvertretender
chefredakteur beim freitag ich freue
mich auf annette binninger mitglied der
chefredaktion der sächsischen zeitung
und sonja alvarez ist baron
stellvertretende büroleiter der politik
bei der wirtschaftswoche in berlin
schlage vor wir fangen mit dem man an
denen wir gelegentlich hören nicht immer
verstehen aber der am donnerstag zu
diesem thema ein statement abgegeben hat
bundeskanzler stolzen
ich habe gesagt you'll never walk alone
in den nächsten wochen werden wir ein
drittes entlastungs paket schnüren um
den großen druck der auf vielen
bürgerinnen und bürgern aber auch
unternehmen lastet abzumildern wie das
paket genau aussieht besprechen wir
vertrauensvoll in der regierung die
gerechtigkeitsfrage ist entscheidend
damit das land in dieser krise zusammen
bleibt ich würde gern bevor wir
versuchen uns einen überblick zu
verschaffen versuchen eigentlich 3 w
fragen für alvarez zu beantworten also
wer verdient eigentlich entlastungen wie
viel wäre fair und gerecht und wie kann
das ganze passieren lassen sie uns mal
mit dem wehr anfangen wer verdient und
braucht entlastung das ist jetzt
natürlich die ganz große frage und wir
haben es gerade den kanzler gehört
you're never walk alone was aber eben
nicht heißen kann tatsächlich dass in
diesen kalten zeiten ist eine warme
dusche für alle gibt sondern genau nicht
für alle aber für gering eben nicht für
alle und da muss eben ganz klar
nachgearbeitet werden wir sehen bisher
dass vor allen dingen nach dem prinzip
gießkanne entlastet wird das werden auch
diejenigen entlastet die eben nicht so
sehr getroffen sind oder sich eben diese
sprache und deutlich besser leisten
können und da muss die regierung eben
gezielt nach steuern aber das ist eben
die große frage wie das wie das gelingt
aber billiger für wen und verbilligt für
diejenigen die es brauchen also ich bin
ich glaube eine warme dusche werden wir
noch alle uns leisten können der
waschlappen ist nicht für alle gefragt
glaube ich alleine aber es muss darum
gehen das stimmt mich für alles zu geben
von diesem gießkannenprinzip weg zu
denen wirklich zu kommen die es brauchen
dies notwendig haben das ist jetzt sehr
viel sozialpolitik gefragt in dieser
energiekrise und mir ist da noch zuviel
unbestimmt unklar und auch unabsehbar
wen ist wirklich unterstützt und das
glaube ich da muss schnell knaller
klarheit her da kann man herausfinden
wer es braucht gibt es dafür harte
kriterien
naja es gibt bestimmte kriterien die
jetzt ja auch kolportierten diskutiert
werden bestimmte einkommensgrenzen und
so weiter ich glaube man muss vor allem
eine gruppe blick haben über die die
ganz arg in die bredouille ist und das
sind diejenigen die eben keine
sozialleistungen beziehen aber nur ein
bisschen mehr verdienen als eben die
sozialleistung es vorsehen und da gibt
es sogar mechanismen der deutsche
sozialstaat ist so schlecht und gekürzt
jetzt ja auch wieder nicht es gibt die
möglichkeit zum sozialamt zum shop
jobcenter zu gehen und bei einer hohen
einmal nachforderungen die auf einen
zukommt die dann hilfen zu beantragen
und mithin bis zu die hälfte dieser nach
zahlungs kosten erstattet zu kriegen das
wissen aber viele menschen einfach gar
nicht darum ist es auch eine frage der
information der offensiven
informationspolitik um die hilfe
wirklich gezielt bei denen ankommen zu
lassen die sie brauchen und das sind
natürlich in aller erster linie auch all
g2 und hartz4 empfänger klar die müssen
gerade auch für nahrung wahnsinnig viel
mehr ausgeben für herbst sie haben
genügt also lässt es sich klar
rausfinden zielgerichtet die zu finden
die es brauchen ganz so einfach ist es
nicht ich mache mir noch um diejenigen
sorgen die sich große sorgen machen dass
sie abrutschen die zu denjenigen gehören
die mehr verdienen es klingt die
sozialleistungen beziehen und jetzt in
eine bredouille kommen und gefördert
wurden aber in der vergangenheit mit
allen maßnahmen fast immer alle lang
rabatt alle
gas umlage alle sind betroffen die
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung bekommen auch
alle auch die die nicht betroffen sind
das kommt dass er völlig irre das
hauptproblem das wir haben ist gar nicht
ein thema der falschen entscheidungen
die getroffen wurden sondern auch der
kommunikation kanzler und koalition
erwecken völlig falsche
erwartungshaltung das führt zu immer
mehr ansprüchen und zu immer größeren
enttäuschung auch bei denjenigen die
nicht bedürftig sind
wie viel also ich fahre mal zusammen sie
haben es unterschiedlich konkret gemacht
die die es brauchen keine dusche für
alle ja so ein bereich wo man arbeitet
eigentlich von seinem geld leben kann
aber es knapp wird wenn es zu wenig ist
ja jetzt wie viel frau alvarez
kriege ich sollte ich wenn ich bedürftig
bin all das ausgeglichen bekommen das
jetzt bei der rechnung drauf kommt wie
viel ausgleich nun ist es tatsächlich so
dass die regierung schon entlastungs
paket auf den weg gebracht hat einen
umfang von 30 milliarden euro gibt es
zwei pakete und da hat es ja auch
durchaus für die bedürftigen schon
entlastungen gegeben es gab den
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
bezieher auch azubis wurden unterstützt
und es gibt ja auch die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage die zuerst juli gegriffen hat
dadurch 66 milliarden euro entlastung
ermöglicht worden
aber natürlich ist es jetzt so dass noch
mal geschaut werden muss wie bei dem
wird das gerade wirklich eng und da ist
es tatsächlich so dass das eben nicht
nur die ganz unteren klassen sind
sondern es geht auch um um familien die
die jetzt bald womöglich vierstellige
energiepreis nachzahlung haben oder die
rechnung haben und und dann auch das ist
natürlich ein betrag den den familien
dann durchaus merken wie viel also sie
haben angefangen ich habe auch einfach
mal zumindest sag ich mal so viele auf
meine karte passte versuchte
auszuschreiben sie haben schon gesagt
eeg-umlage ist weggefallen senkung der
pendlerpauschale hörer kinderzuschlag
bei geringem einkommen
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
weiter kinderbonus einmalzahlungen für
transferempfänger tank rabatt 9 euro
ticket eine energiepreis pauschale die
im september alle die arbeiten mit dem
gehalt bekommen da habe ich schluss
gemacht meine frage war wie viel das
klingt nach sehr viel reicht das schon
brauchen wir dieses nächste paket noch
ich glaube wir brauchen das ganz sicher
weil man jetzt schon absehen kann
beziehungsweise viele leute können jetzt
noch nicht absehen wie sehr es sie
trifft und ich glaube das ist die große
problematik auch für die politik jetzt
was kommt von dieser ganz langen liste
das klingt ja ungeheuer viel auf an
leistungen und es sind tatsächlich auch
ungeheuer viele leistungen geflossen
sind aber die frage ist wo wirklich am
ende bedürftigkeit ein schwer ist als
jetzt noch absehbar ist und ich glaube
dass das nicht nur bei den hartz 4
empfänger bei den alb 2 und so weiter
sein wird sondern es wird eben auch eine
untere mittelschicht geben bei denen
nachgelegt werden muss und zwar gezielt
nachgelegt werden muss und intelligent
nachgelegt werden muss aber auch immer
dazu gesagt werden muss es wird nicht
für alle einen vollen ausgleich dieser
mehrbelastung geben und das ist so etwas
wo ich sage momentan hat man den
eindruck auch die durch die diskussion
so wie sie läuft als wenn alles
kompensiert werden wird und das wird es
nicht sein
und deswegen gilt es wirklich
intelligent mechanismen zu finden die
leute herauszufinden ich glaube übrigens
dass er auch rentnern vielmehr dazu
gehören als wir das jetzt noch sehen die
vielfach leer ausgegangen sind liebe
gruppe der geringverdiener auch also
wenn ich jetzt nur mal für den osten
sprecher wir haben jeder dritte ist
geringverdiener in sachsen
beispielsweise auch in anderen ost
westlichen bundesländern sie haben dort
dann rutschen jetzt immer mehr leute
rein in die frage auch durchaus lohnt es
sich für mich noch arbeiten zu gehen
oder hab ich nicht lieber besser von
hartz4 sogar das bessere los das ist
eine irre situation die sich da
entwickelt gerade und ich glaube
deswegen muss man auf master puschner
herbst es ist wahnsinnig schwierig das
zu beziffern in seinem umfang weil wir
gar nicht wissen wie sich der gaspreis
weiterentwickeln wird aber was schon
auffällt ist dass diese lösung die jetzt
gefunden wurde mit der gas umlage und
der mehrwertsteuerabsenkung wirklich
also bei der frage ich mich ob das ziel
der ampel eigentlich ist die
zerstrittene deutsche ökonomen
landschaft zu also zu einigen weil da
sind das leben allein
es gibt und das ist erstaunlich es gibt
nämlich eigentlich ein modell bei der
bei dem man dann doch mit bezifferbaren
zahlen arbeiten kann und das meiner
meinung nach viel besser gewesen wäre
das seit februar eine diskussion ist das
ist ein preis deckel für den grund
verbrauch da sagt man dann einfach
lassen und gleich separat gern auch mal
gerne als umlage weil sie so
kompliziertes herbst die rentnerinnen
und rentner würde ich gerne noch mal in
denen in den fokus rücken des saarland
ist zum beispiel eine region mit einer
besonders hohen eigenheimquote viele
rentnerinnen und rentner sind vermögend
weil sie ein großes haus auf einem
großen grundstück haben das ist aber
energetisch im regelfall nicht besonders
gut saniert diese gruppe wird es
besonders hart treffen die werden etwas
aufgeben müssen wofür sie in ihrem leben
gespart haben und wo sie nicht raus
wollen das sind glaube ich oder das ist
glaube ich eine gruppe die noch allzu
wenige im fokus haben jenseits der
großen städte sehr sehr viel auf dem
land große häuser energetisch schlecht
von rentnerinnen und rentnern bewohnt
die sich das einfach nicht mehr leisten
können dort werden sich dramen abspielen
und die muss man deshalb im fokus haben
zeigt wie individuell die
lebenssituation sein kann ich sage ihnen
schon mal danke wie jede woche sind sie
dabei in den sozialen netzwerken bei
tagesschau.de presseclub de verfolgen
die sendung und kommentieren bei dem was
ich bisher gelesen habe ja sag mal
klingt ganz überwiegend durch das viele
nicht glauben dass die entlastungen
wirklich helfen wirklich zielgerichtet
sind jetzt haben sie beide in der
diskussion eben gesagt naja man weiß ja
noch gar nicht so genau wie hart es am
ende wirklich kommt ist
es dann richtig jetzt so viele konkrete
einzelmaßnahmen zu diskutieren wenn man
nicht mal genau war es wie tief der
schlag wird nun ja es ist tatsächlich so
dass
viele kollegen hat es gerade schon
gesagt wieder haben doch dieser alten
beziehen noch dass die energie zu dem
alten preis der der neue preis ist noch
tatsächlich gar nicht durchgeschlagen
das wird sich erst im nächsten jahr dann
bemerkbar machen und deswegen beim thema
mehr beim thema gas anlage sind da sind
ist jetzt dir 2,4 cent jetzt darauf
kommen tatsächlich dann eigentlich nur
noch geringer betrag das wird noch
deutlich mehr werden aber umso wichtiger
ist es jetzt eigentlich jetzt für für
anreize zu sorgen dass jetzt eben
energie gespart wir tatsächlich denn was
ihm keinesfalls passieren darf ist dass
wir in diese gasmenge lage kommen und
dann eben das gas verteilt werden muss
dass produktion gestoppt werden müssen
das würde den wirtschaftsstandort eben
sehr gefährden wie geht man denn mit dem
widerspruch um sie sagen das müsst ihr
jetzt der anreiz geschaffen werden
energie gas zu sparen das tut man
normalerweise in dem man es knapper und
teurer macht und auf der anderen seite
reden wir darüber dass geholfen werden
muss damit man gas bezahlen muss das
heißt dann preis senken wie kommt man
aus diesem jahr aber das ist ja auch
tatsächlich von der regierung da sind
sehr widersprüchliche signale ja auf der
einen seite wird wird dass wir das
gaspreis teurer gemacht ja das so reden
wir jetzt über die gasanlage merke das
ist das anschauen
wir kommen gar nicht drum hintern sind
auch sie wieder dran
natürlich zum sparen an ging dann wird
aber wiederum die mehrwertsteuer darauf
gesenkt was dann durch das sparen
wiederum nicht so viel attraktiver macht
ja und das ist einfach ein großer
widerspruch in dem sich die regierung
hier mit ihrem konzept befindet und was
eigentlich sehr fragwürdig ist auch
handwerklich ganz schlecht gemacht ich
glaube das muss man auch einmal sagen da
wird eine gasanlage
gemacht im wissen darum dass es darauf
eine mehrwertsteuer gibt herr lindner
sagt naja wir kriegen das irgendwie mit
der überschwemmung erreicht ist das
europarecht ist kann das schon irgendwie
mit der eu hin er hat es nicht
hinbekommen so und dann weil dabei die
auch bei der aufschrei groß ist kommt
auf die belastung eine entlastung aber
das ist doch ganz verrückt man jetzt
doch viel einfacher machen können es gab
bei der lufthansa es gab bei den banken
das thema systemrelevanz und zweifellos
ist uniqa um die geht es im wesentlichen
der größte gasimporteur der viele
stadtwerke beliefert derjenige der
gerettet werden mussten sonst wäre es in
der tat ein riesen problem geworden aber
ich hätte den doch geübt in deutschland
ohne wählerinnen und wähler bürgerinnen
und bürger völlig zu verwirren und
verrückt zu machen direkt unterstützen
können das wollte der
bundesfinanzminister nicht weil es
direkt aus dem bundeshaushalt passiert
werde das muss man im hintergrund wissen
das ist dort passiert und alle menschen
baden zurzeit aus dass sich diese
bundesregierung intern nicht einig ist
dass lindt nahrung gegen grün genau ich
habe herrn puschner dummerweise bei der
gas- und klage kippen unterbrochen in
der annahme könnten das noch ein
bisschen aufschieben und sie sind dran
jetzt ist es soweit ich stimme dem
völlig zu und wie gerade eben schon
gesagt es gibt ein modell das weitaus
besser gewesen wäre meiner meinung nach
und das auch nach wie vor sich immer
noch anbietet und das ist ein preis
deckel auf dem grund verbrauch man
definiert eine bestimmte menge ich
glaube in beispielrechnungen ist 180
8000 kilowattstunden die rede legt den
preis darauf fest und sagt bis dahin
garantieren wir es kostet nicht mehr der
preis steigt nicht er wird gedeckelt und
das heißt darüber hinaus sondern
sozusagen für sachen für weil sie nicht
pro kopf oder pro familienhaushalt ein
bestimmtes kontingent für alle gleich
und das kriege ich zum vorjahrespreis
oder ja dass das oder zum subventioniert
das ist natürlich den
bundesfinanzminister wahrscheinlich
ähnlich unrecht wie ein direkter
einstieg bei juniper bezahlt aus dem
bundeshaushalt aber es ermöglicht eben
auch über dieses grundkonzept kontingent
hinaus dann die spahn reize zu setzen
weil man dort die energie verteuern kann
und dann auch sagen kann ok jeder ist
erstmal sicher jeder bekommt seinen
grund verbrauch gedeckt und muss ich da
keine sorgen machen aber alles was
darüber hinausgeht da setzt man den
sparern du bist ein grüner werden nicht
wahr werden
ich kann da nur zustimmen also ich
glaube dass diese gaspreis deckelung
viel zu spät auch überlegt wurde in die
diskussion auch mit reingenommen wurde
und sie hat einen beruhigenden effekt
auch auf die leute und ich glaube man
darf das nicht vergessen in dieser
ganzen aufgeregten diskussion diese live
verfolgung der twittert lindner
irgendeinen vorschlag raus und dann am
nächsten tag ist er wieder weg und so
weiter braucht man auch klare aussagen
wo hilfe läuft und diese gaspreis
deckelung wäre ein ganz simples
einfaches modell gewesen was jeder
sofort bestand nett und was auch nicht
zwei tage später wieder einem halben
effekt einkassiert worden wäre oder
sonst was alles also ich habe dazu noch
eine frage das ist ja einen vorschlag
der von jens spahn cdu unterstützt wird
von linken politikern von grünen
politikerin
von cdu über grün bis links
entweder muss das total verrückt sein
oder total vernünftig also ist eine
seltene konstellation
warum ist das nicht passiert einfach nur
weil es zu spät in der diskussion
vielleicht ist es auch ein punkte dass
man so viel die alten pfade der sozialen
marktwirtschaft gerade verlässt und in
so vielen dingen der staat gerade
eingreift dass man sagt jetzt müssen wir
doch wenigstens davor sich als
stattlicher preis natürlich und es ist
eine regulierung durch den staat und ich
glaube auch es hat etwas damit zu tun
dass wir natürlich alle nicht absehen
können wie lange das ganze geht momentan
hat man so ein bisschen den eindruck wir
tun gerade alles um die leute über
diesen winter zu bringen wir wissen noch
gar nicht wie viele winter es sein
werden und wir reden noch gar nicht über
die gestiegenen lebenshaltungskosten die
inflation und so weiter die ja auch dazu
massiv beigetragen hat dass das geld
beim einzelnen zu knapp teilen sie die
einschätzung dass die sorge vor einem
staatlich festgelegten gaspreis der
grund war ja und bei die union jetzt
nicht dass sozialismus fertig aber
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass hat sich
erst mal gut an man deckelt einen preis
ja aber wir leben nun mal wir haben eine
marktwirtschaft eine soziale
marktwirtschaft und da ist es eigentlich
richtig dass man die preise wirken lässt
und über die preise dann steuert und
dann aber eben ganz gezielt entlastet ja
deswegen finde ich sehr dieser preis
deckels hat sich gut an aber ist in dem
fall tatsächlich nicht die richtige
maßnahme man musste daher gezielte
entlastungen machen ok
preis decke löst auch nicht alle
probleme ich bleibe bei meinen
rentnerinnen und rentnern von lieben die
brauchen mehr als als auch auf das was
gedeckelt und
die kommen mit dem modell immer noch in
probleme nur eine solche maßnahme auch
wenn sie nicht unproblematisch ist da
bin ich ganz bei der kollegin hat den
großen vorteil jeder versteht sie sofort
und bleibe dabei eines der größten
probleme heute ist das manchmal sogar zu
viel geholfen wird das lädt zu
missbrauchen dort landet geld bei denen
die es gar nicht benötigen weil sie
diese lasten selber schultern könnten
und das sorgt auch für unwohlsein bei
vielen die nämlich am ende des tages
irgendwann die zeche zahlen müssen weil
das geld kommt ja nicht aus der
privatschatulle von herrn lindner auch
nicht aus wehrt des kanzlers sondern es
sind steuergelder und am ende zahlt
immer der steuerzahler die zeche und
wenn er nicht selbst dann die nächste
generation ich fasse mal zusammen
wahrscheinlich ist das was mit der
gasanlage passiert ist ein unfall also
es wird jedenfalls nicht wie einen 'plan
dass man anfang der woche anhebt um
mitte der woche er ist ein unfall serie
ja es ist ja schon das ist ja schon ein
unfall in folge tank rabatt
wir können ja vielleicht später auch
noch darüber sprechen warum der
regierung so schwer fällt dort einen
kurs zu finden aber vielleicht tun wir
das in dem wir ob das gucken was
mehrfach angekündigt wurde von olaf
scholz heute auch wieder von anderen
regierungsmitglieder in das sogenannte
dritte
entlastungspaket wir ahnen was einzelne
koalitionspartner vielleicht möchten wir
wissen aber nicht was am ende drin steht
deshalb möchte ich noch mal mit ihnen
aufgreifen wer aus ihrer sicht im fokus
sein sollte wir haben vorhin über
sogenannte transferempfänger gesprochen
also ich sag mal hartz iv bezieherinnen
und bezieher
vermutlich müssen wir nicht darüber
diskutieren dass dort der sozialstaat in
der pflicht ist es hat auch niemand
verneinend den kopf geschüttelt als wir
über geringverdiener gesprochen haben
jetzt gibt es aber die gruppe der
rentnerinnen und rentner das ist ja eine
zum teil sehr wohlhabende gruppe das ist
die generation die vererbt die vermögen
aufgebaut hat
nicht durchgehend es gibt auch arme
rentnerinnen und rentner aber ich sag
mal verglichen mit allein erziehenden
wissen wir dass rentnerin rentner fiel
wohl haben da sind es ihnen viel besser
geht also kommen wir zu dieser gruppe
verdienen die als gruppe eine entlastung
selbst wenn sie hohes vermögen haben ich
glaube dass man da einen weg suchen muss
differenziert vorzugehen also die
rentner im saarland unterscheiden sich
sehr von den rentnern in sachsen würde
ich mal sagen und sie sprachen vorhin
von den von den eigenheimen die
energetisch nicht gut saniert sind die
eigentumsquote in ostdeutschland ist
wesentlich geringer ja also da haben wir
eine andere problematik
und ich glaube dass man auch da genauer
hinsehen muss wer wirklich dort
bedürftig ist und
passgenauer das irgendwie machen muss
ich gestehe ich habe das weise keine
pauschale für alle würde ich nicht und
ich glaube das ist ein falsches signal
jetzt auch gerade weil das ist ja auch
einen generationenvertrag der jetzt
läuft quasi so ein
ungeschriebener der oder oder ohne
ausgedrückte der der wo jung und alt
jetzt auch zusammen eine unglaubliche
leistung erbringen müssen und ich glaube
dass es sehr sehr schwierig wäre wenn
man jetzt pauschal gerade auch an die
rentner generation
alles gibt und zu viel gibt und dann
wieder dort außerdem unterstrich ja es
ist ja nicht das unterscheidungsmerkmal
alt jung unbedingt oder rentner nicht
rentner es ist mein reich einkommen
stark einkommen schwach ich habe jetzt
auch nicht die die die lösung parat wie
rentnerinnen und rentner zu entlasten
sind aber dass diese energie pauschale
zum beispiel auf sie nicht denn viele
oder so weiter hat natürlich für viel
unmut gesorgt und genau solche
situationen wie sie sie geschildert
einer leeren das sind die 300 euro in
jeder der arbeitet im nächsten monat mit
lohn und gehalt ausgezahlt bekommt aber
eben ausschließlich
berufstätige und eben nicht rentner der
steckdose ein bisschen der gedanke
hinter die müssen nicht zur arbeit
fahren es gab schon die idee dahinter
aber das ist sozusagen das was ihm an
genau und wir hatten es ja wir hatten es
ja eben gerade schon ich meine
rentnerinnen und rentner wie sie den
fall beschrieben haben aus dem saarland
es gibt vom paritätischen gesamtverband
oder so auch eine förderung die
forderung genau für solche situationen
das ist jetzt kein akutes rettungspaket
aber so mal auf die auf die mittlere
frist auch energetische sanierungen zu
subventionieren damit auch diese
menschen diese häuser die er
wahrscheinlich noch weiter dort auf den
großen grundstücken stehen werden eben
energetisch fit zu machen das wäre ja
mal für die längere zeit zumindest ein
ansatz alter ist ja ich möchte darauf
hinweisen dass die rentner nicht ganz
leer ausgegangen sind oder ausgehen das
ist ja tatsächlich so dass sie von der
abschaffung der eeg-umlage durchaus
profitiert haben und
bei der energiepreis pauschale von 300
euro brutto ist es jetzt natürlich so
dass die weil es kein besseres system
offensichtlich gibt über über den lohn
dann an die angestellten ausgezahlt
werden aber auch da gibt es ja auf die
rentnerinnen und rentner durchaus die
möglichkeit auch diese pauschale zu
bekommen indem sie da wurden ja auch
schon verschiedene modelle diskutiert
dass sie müssen glaube ich nur einen tag
im jahr als mini jobber gearbeitet haben
und können das dann geltend machen
würden dann im nächsten jahr dann diese
energiepreis pauschale tatsächlich
bekommen herr herbst sie haben eben
schon mal luft geholt um über den
zustand die zusammensetzung der
bundesregierung zu sprechen haben sie
denn eine vermutung wie dieses paket
jetzt gepackt wird was reinkommt wer was
rein legen möchte also ich halte das
zurzeit für unkalkulierbar und
irgendeiner wird sich dort bewegen
müssen und der kanzler wird auch mal
führungskompetenz zeigen müssen er wird
nicht nur in der krisenkommunikation
besser werden müssen sondern auch in
krisen management sa deren flicken
management im management seiner
koalition dort steht immer die fdp gegen
die grünen und wenn ich in einer so
dramatischen notlage bin dann müssen
doch eigentlich zum beispiel der
wirtschaftsminister und der
finanzminister ganz eng beieinander
seien das gegenteil ist der fall ich
erlebe zwar manchmal herrn habe der
wahrscheinlich mit faust in der tasche
das ein oder andere begründet was man so
von ihm nicht erwartet hätte aber das
ist doch das ist doch ein thema das
macht sich ja nicht nur an über gewinn
steuer sondern an vielem anderen auch
wieder fest wo man den eindruck hat zum
schluss kriegen beide etwas und das
macht es so widersprüchlich deshalb sind
es auch so viele kleine maßnahmen
das hat mit dieser situation dieser
koalition zu tun die zwar gut gestartet
ist aber sich in dieser krise jetzt
nicht bewerten wer weiß mehr wer ahnt
was angepackt wird herr pushen denn
vielleicht die naja ich denke mal dass
den grünen daran gelegen sein wird in
irgendeiner form eine nachfolge für das
neue euro ticket zu finden oder
festzuklopfen das ist übrigens auch eine
dieser gießkannen maßnahmen von denen
ich sagen würde die sind gut und die
sind richtig und von denen haben alle
was und auch wenn sie die sage ich mal
dass das das
bild darauf gelenkt haben den blick
darauf gelenkt haben wie der zustand der
bahn ist aber das ist was mit dem diese
regierung ja auch eine gewisse euphorie
entfacht hat und wo ich wirklich nicht
versteht dass wenn auch noch die
arbeitgebernahe ökonom attestieren das
ist eine inflations dämpfende wirkung
hatte warum diese fortsetzung nicht
schon längst verkündet ist also ich
würde mal sagen ich würde mal sagen wenn
das nicht auf jeden fall dabei ist in
diesem paket dann wäre das ein
armutszeugnis für die grünen und dann
sie haben gerade schon die über
gewinnsteuern
erwähnt ich bin gespannt weil es geht ja
nicht nur um entlastungen es geht auch
um belastungen um die frage wer die
lasten trägt das wäre auf jeden fall ein
punkt an dem sollte allen drei
koalitionären eigentlich gelegen sein zu
zeigen dass diejenigen die in dieser
krise profitieren auch ihren teil
abgeben müssen würde ich gleich noch mal
darauf zurückkommen lassen sie uns noch
sammeln also sie haben was reingelegt in
der oder mögliche elemente reingelegt in
das paket also ich glaube man wird jeder
wird etwas abkriegen vom kuchen dass er
seiner klientel sagen kann das habe ich
durchgesetzt so wie immer leider ist ein
dreier koalition die haben ja auch
leidvolle in sachsen sein wird ein euro
ticket glaube ich dass es so nicht mehr
geben wird es wird wenn entweder sehr
viel teurer werden und ich könnte mir
auch vorstellen und finde das auch gar
nicht schlecht es doch auch bestimmte
gruppen ein bisschen zu fokussieren weil
der große effekt den man jetzt auch sich
erwartet hatte dass die leute ihr auto
stehen lassen deswegen den erreichen sie
bei gerade bei pendlern und so weiter
ist das keine große hilfe ansonsten in
normalen zeiten würde ich mir wünschen
dass man solche dinge mal auch macht
ausprobiert auch mehr weil sie natürlich
zeigen wie einfach es ist auf einmal
alle tarifsystem in den ländern über den
haufen zu werfen das war ein wunderbarer
effekt so einfach kann es sein ich
glaube es ist wenn wir bei dieser art
und weise nicht mehr haben über gewinn
steuer dann wird sich die fdp
unglaublich schwer tun damit wir müssen
sie jetzt einmal zu glaub ich einmal
stimmen was die über gewinn steuer ist
also dass man das was man über einen
normalen gewinn hinaus erwirtschaftet
hat durch die oder in der krise dann
auch wieder abführen soll da wird es die
große problematik geben dass du
überhaupt zu definieren wo der normale
gewinn ist und was darüber hinaus geht
insofern ich glaube ich würde man sich
dann noch lange die zähne daran ausbeißt
ich glaube nicht dass es unbedingt dran
sein wird aber es wären dann solche
dinge drin sein wie noch einmal die
zuschuss das von gehe ich aus auch da
würde ich mir wünschen passgenauer
gruppen zu definieren vielleicht auch in
unterschiedlichen höhen also weil für
bestimmte einkommensgruppen diese 300
euro sind dann 140 150 euro das ein für
eine gruppe die ist überhaupt nicht
braucht und ich glaube da muss man
sorgfältig steuersatz habe weil ich
verdiene plus netto übrig das legen sie
ran ja ich möchte auch noch mal kurz
auch die energie über gewinn steuer
eingehen sie sagen sind gespannt was
reinkommt also ich glaube es steht schon
fest dass die nicht rein kommen wird
weil die fdp im sich tatsächlich sehr
dagegen sperrt angela merkel hat immer
gerne gesagt politik ist das was möglich
ist und das ist eben mit der fdp
tatsächlich nicht möglich und da muss
man eben auch dann an den
wirtschaftsstandort einmal denken weil
es für unternehmen dann natürlich
schwierig ist zu wissen sie wissen ja
gar nicht wann werden sie womöglich eine
über gewinn steuer haben und das
steuersystem unterscheide jetzt ja auch
nicht zwischen guten und schlechten euro
ist ja ein pharmaunternehmen wie
biontech das müsste dann eben in so
einem fall dann womöglich auch eine über
gewinn steuer zahlen müssen milliarden
und milliarden an genau und es ist ja
eigentlich wenn man jetzt auch gute
sozialpolitik ist eben guter
wirtschaftspolitik und und da muss man
dann eben auch an den standort denken
und unternehmen anreizen in innovationen
zu investieren die sich dann natürlich
auch in gewinnen erschlagen die frage
die dahinter steckt ist ja wo soll das
geld herkommen wir haben die
schuldenbremse im grundgesetz wir haben
eine diskussion darüber ob man die
einhalten muss oder wir in einer notlage
sind wo der staat noch mehr schulden
machen kann
und die alternative wäre eben
zusätzliche einnahmen die aber nach
koalitionsvertrag steuererhöhungen fdp
wahrscheinlich nicht kommen
wie tief darf der staat denn in die
tasche greifen und weitere schulden
aufnehmen
sollte helfen aber er sollte auch
vorsichtig sein er sollte nicht
verschwenden sollte nicht zu
missbrauchen animieren das haben wir in
der vergangenheit in corona zeiten an
vielen stellen gehabt möchte sind auch
steuergelder missbraucht worden und dort
hatte es grundlagen geben fahrlässig es
war ich bleib bei deinem wort
handwerklich schlecht gemacht ich will
noch ein thema einbringen das noch nicht
gefallen ist der grünen-chef hat es
jetzt mal thematisiert an sie
dienstwagenprivileg anzugehen und das
sozusagen so zu gestalten
dass könnte ich mir vorstellen dass
darüber diskutiert wird wie übergeben
steuer halte ich auch für extrem
problematisch
vor allen dingen weil diejenigen die am
meisten
ungerechtfertig profitiert haben ihre
gewinne ja gar nicht in deutschland
versteuern sondern in großbritannien die
großen mineralölkonzerne haben die
italiener auch schon gemerkt dass über
gewinne steuern nicht funktioniert also
auch hier haben politisch diejenigen die
das thema vorantreiben erwartungen
geweckt die sie gar nicht erfüllen
können nicht nur weil es die fdp nicht
will sondern weil es praktisch auch kaum
geht ohne so in das wirtschaftssystem
einzugreifen und auch in die
steuerhoheit anderer länder einzugreifen
da wird es ein bisschen da wird es ein
bisschen schwierig ich habe eingangs der
sendung gesagt
es hat mir niemand widersprochen wir
haben es aber auch nicht diskutiert
dass wir als gesellschaft und auch die
bundesregierung vermutlich vor der
bisher härtesten bewährungsprobe stehen
unsere diskussion ist ziemlich sachlich
und moderat also bei dem was wir jetzt
besprochen haben reden wir über
zielgenaue maßnahmen keine verschwendung
erstmal abwarten wie schlimm das ganze
wirklich wird
habe ich übertrieben und übertreiben
diejenigen die von sozialen unruhen
sprechen sind das einfach sagt mal
politische krisengewinnler die das
aufbauschen und in wirklichkeit haben
wir alles im griff und sind auf kurs
nein ist es tatsächlich so dass schon
die
linksfraktion angekündigt hat
montagsdemonstrationen
montag demonstration aufzurufen um sich
gegen diese
maßnahme neben zu werden gerade im osten
da kann kollegen sich auch kleine mann
mehr zu sagen
der dort seinen bürgerinnen und bürger
im besonders stark betroffenen insofern
wird es da auf alle fälle einen heißen
herbst geben aber umso wichtiger ist
eben eine deutlich bessere
krisenkommunikation durch den kanzler
und wir haben ihnen diese woche erlebt
ich habe die zeit gestoppt dass er war
er hat die mehrwertsteuersenkung
verkündet da war er eine minute und 43
sekunden auf der bühne und dann war er
schon wieder weg also
krisenkommunikation geht anders
der vorgänger ja olaf scholz war ja
nicht nur diese kurze zeit vor der
kamera diese woche sondern stand auch
vom untersuchungsausschuss zu comics ich
glaube dank guter großartiger
journalistische arbeit vieler
kolleginnen und kollegen wissen die
menschen in deutschland inzwischen auch
ganz genau was dieses comics ist und ich
will den blick da noch mal ein bisschen
weiter und sagen sie sehen da ist ein
kanzler der hat irgendwas mit diesem
skandal zu tun erinnert sich aber an
nichts sie sehen ein cdu-chef fliegt mit
seinem privatflugzeug zum rauschenden
hochzeitsfest des finanzministers nach
sylt sie sehen was im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk los ist als es gibt
glaube ich um mal hier so ein bisschen
die harmonie und die sachlichkeit ein
bisschen vielleicht nochmal aufzubrechen
durchaus grund für menschen auf die idee
zu blicken und zu sagen ich muss gucken
wie ich meine rechnungen bezahlen und
andere leben in saus und braus oder
profitieren von dieser krise und darum
nochmal über gewinnt steuer ich muss
nochmal darauf zurückkommen es gibt sehr
wohl zahlen es gibt sehr wohl an setzte
es gibt historische vorbilder in den
weltkriegen in den usa in großbritannien
in frankreich es sind ist ein instrument
das wurde immer wieder auch gerade wegen
des gerechtigkeitsempfinden der menschen
auch wenn das aufkommen vielleicht nicht
die ausgaben deckt keine frage und bp
seine gewinne zum beispiel nicht nur in
großbritannien sondern auch in singapur
versteuert weil da der satz von fünf
prozent nur drauf dann zum tragen kommt
also ich glaube ein solches ohne ein
solches signal das zeigt okay wir sehen
dass hier eigentlich so walter
gerechtigkeit ja
gehen wir schon durchaus vielleicht in
einen heißen herbst
also ich glaube man muss jetzt sehr gut
darauf achten auch von der
bundesregierung aus dass man eben nicht
nur zahlen modelle ideen und so weiter
immer wieder vorlegt und durchrechnet
und wieder verwirft und so weiter
sondern man muss die menschen auch
nichts mitnehmen und ich glaube nicht
dass so ein satz von bundeskanzler
scholz you never walk alone reicht
ganz sicher nicht um die menschen durch
diese krise hindurch zu führen und auch
vertrauen zu schaffen weil ein gewisses
grundvertrauen muss da sein und ich wir
merken schon jetzt im osten oder sachsen
jetzt ganz konkret sehr dass sich jetzt
wieder die auch die afd beginnt auf
dieses thema ein zu spielen sehr
deutlich schon los peitscht und eine
abgeordnete spricht gerade von einem
krieg gegen das eigene volk was die
bundesregierung führen würde wir merken
dass da verbal unglaubliche
radikalisierung läuft das jetzt auf
verfassungsschützer schon warnen davor
wir sind ja einiges gewohnt in sachsen
die montagsdemos gibt's bei uns
weitgehend durchgehend immer noch die
strukturen sind vorhanden und natürlich
ist aber uns eine sorge da das auch das
jetzt wieder mit radikalen
protesten auch gefüllt wird und das ist
schon eine möglichkeit die ich sehe die
ich auch befürchtet dass das so laufen
wird und umso mehr muss man auch auf
eines aufpassen würde dass wir gar nicht
gesprochen haben weil es geht nicht nur
um maßnahmen und entlastung belastung es
geht auch darum die begründung warum ist
das notwendig warum tun wir das das
nicht außen vor zu lassen glaube ich
sondern den menschen auch diese basis
der akzeptanz die muss erhalten bleiben
sonst kriegen sie deutschland nicht
durch diese krise durch und dann merke
ich oft dass es schon bröckelt und ich
habe da auch mich sehr gewundert also
dass unser ministerpräsident
bundes cdu vize da auch sehr wackelig
ist und auch signale dort sendet also
dass man dürfe sich nicht jeden konflikt
dieser welt zu eigen machen das wäre das
der untergang und man müsse vorsichtig
sein und russisches gas doch wieder und
ich glaube diese basis beginnt zu der
akzeptanz beginnt zu bröckeln
und wenn politik da nicht aufpasst dann
brauchen wir über das andere gar nicht
mehr reden dann wird es sehr unruhig und
ungemütlich werden
herbst ich streue nur mal ein also die
zufriedenheit mit der bundesregierung
ist auf einem tiefstand vor allem die
spd ist abgesagt
17% im deutschlandtrend diese woche ist
sind vor allem spd politiker die
schlechte werte haben ja und das war als
einschub dann sind sie dann ja gut der
bundesfinanzminister hat auch keine
besonders guten werte der
oppositionsführer rat auch keine
besonders guten werte zur zeit haben
einige an wer eine flächendeckende
vertrauenskrise ich glaube ja und ich
habe auch an dem weise vertrauenskrise
ja ich glaube wir haben eine
vertrauenskrise und weil ich selber
lange auch in sachsen gelebt und
gearbeitet habe bin ich ganz bei annette
binninger dort gärt ist dass sie hin wir
noch nicht so stark aber nach
flüchtlingen corona querdenkern hat
dieses thema jetzt hohe energiepreise
inflation die unmittelbare betroffenheit
von vielen das potenzial dass diejenigen
die bei allem anderen die strippen
gezogen haben hinter den kulissen
sozusagen daraus politisches kapital
schlagen können menschen auf die straße
bringen dagegen muss man etwas tun
empathie ist das eine thema
aber auch ist zu unterlassen genau diese
ganzen
zeichen nach außen zu setzen es gibt
gegen die politische klasse in
deutschland in der aktuellen situation
massive vorbehalte von denen ich auch
sagen würde ohne dass neid eine eine
sozusagen meiner stärksten
charaktereigenschaft ist das ist nicht
in ordnung was dort für zeichen gesetzt
werden dass muss man sich gut überlegen
und natürlich hat jeder die freiheit
hobbyflieger zu sein und natürlich hat
jeder vieles
ich kann auch in krisenzeiten eine tolle
hochzeit feiern aber ist kommt bei
vielen so an das ist das befördert was
an der tübinger beschrieben hat okay wir
sind kurz vor ende der session würde ich
gern noch dazu hören aber ich halte
nochmals ja ein starker satz wenn zu
sagen wir sind in einer politischen
vertrauenskrise und dann habe ich nach
dieser diskussion die frage wenn es
keine einfachen antworten in der sache
gibt das haben wir hier heute mittag
diskutiert das führt uns dann raus aus
der vertrauenskrise na ja ich möchte
noch mal kurz darauf eingehen dass es ja
tatsächlich so ist dass es das jetzt
nicht erwarten können dass die
koalitionäre auf einmal wieder auf
kuschelkurs gehen und sie alle wieder
miteinander vertragen sondern wir stehen
vor der nächsten großen landtagswahl in
niedersachsen am 9 oktober
und da geht es natürlich darum dann auch
den eigenen wählerinnen und wählern
entsprechende signale zu senden was sie
dann davon zu erwarten haben und
deswegen fürchte ich dass wir nicht so
schnell tatsächlich diese kohärente
strategie sehen während die das land
eigentlich wobei die koalitionäre ja
nicht aus jux und dollerei
unterschiedliche projekte vertreten
sondern weil ihre wählerschaft das
jeweils anders erwartet jaja ich
schon mal den gedanken darauf verwenden
dass vielleicht nicht nur aufgrund des
ressentiments gewisser kreise oder
vielleicht das herumlavieren des
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten so sich
sachen artikulieren wir jetzt zum
beispiel in diesem brief von handwerkern
aus sachsen anhalt der vor kurzem konnte
kassierte es ist ja auch irgendwie nicht
so richtig erkennbar dass dieser ansatz
auf diesen furchtbaren krieg zu
reagieren funktioniert also wofür
bringen die menschen eigentlich den
preis fragen sie sich der krieg endet
nicht juristische ökonomie kollabiert
nicht also es ist möglich so unangenehm
dass auch ist schon in sich auch einfach
eine schwierigkeit in dieser situation
die sich da halt eben artikuliert und
dazu kommt dann noch das natürlich ist
auch kaum artikulation kanäle dafür gibt
die linkspartei fällt bis jetzt zum
beispiel für ihre alte rolle als
protestpartei im osten wie 2004 weil ein
hartz vier demonstrationen und so weiter
weitgehend aus er ist mit sich selbst
beschäftigt und dann artikuliert sich
halt verständlicher wut verständliche
gut die leute haben auch sehr sehr sehr
unangenehme art und weise nur ist eine
neue diskussion
also inwiefern der kurs in richtung
sanktionen möglicherweise irgendwann
nicht mehr die unterstützung hat die
heute in der bevölkerung hat aber ich
halte einfach fest zeitenwende im
februar vertrauenskrise heute und da
waren wir uns alle eine eigentlich keine
einfache antwort auf die
herausforderungen danke mich sehr für
diese runde wenn sie in der ard dabei
sind dann jetzt das europamagazin mit
dem bericht aus brüssel und auch einem
energie thema da geht es um die chancen
von wasserstoff und wenn sie im radio
oder bei phoenix dabei sind bitte dran
bleiben dann jetzt presseclub
nachgefragt danke tschüss und lassen
sich gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im fernsehen bei phoenix im
radio bei wdr 5 schön dass sie dabei
sind und ganz besonders danke an michael
micke in hannover sie sind der erste am
telefon hallo hendric gekommen guten tag
hallo
was ist ihre frage ihr argument ja also
meine frage
wer soll das alles bezahlen
wurde ja schon gesagt die kosten werden
wohl die nachkommenden generationen
übernehmen müssen und das nach einer
finanzkrise eurokrise inflation corona
ich weiß nicht ob das alles so richtig
ist wenn man mit den milliarden
verschleudert und ich frage mich warum
nimmt man sich ein beispiel an
frankreich und lachte die bürger einfach
und entlastet die bürger und unternehmer
einfach durch die abschaffung der
rundfunkgebühren 8 milliarden euro
könnte man jährlich sparen und vier
nachkrieg prozent der deutschen wollen
darf auch das ist muss ich sagen nicht
richtig in frankreich wird das ganze
einfach aus dem steuersäckel bezahlt
aber ja wir haben antworten herrschen
ich glaube es würde auch nichts bringen
das ist geld das so zu sagen
jetzt für eben beispielsweise diese
sendung verwendet wird die sie ja
offensichtlich auch ansehen und ich
glaube es gibt viel berechtigte kritik
am öffentlich rechtlichen aber ich würde
sagen mit dem was zum beispiel jetzt die
vorsitzende des sozialverbands vdk frau
bentele
erfordert dass wir über nicht nur eine
über den steuer sondern auch eine
vermögensabgabe reden dass wir wieder
über vermögenssteuern und
erbschaftssteuern in nennenswertem
ausmaß reden das wären
finanzierungsquellen diese wären
zumindest mal durchaus diskutabel und
über gewinn steuer habe ich schon gesagt
außerdem na ja der staat wird auch
nächstes jahr in einem maß kredite
aufnehmen die der schuldenbremse nicht
genügend hüten tun werden da würde ich
alles drauf verwetten weil für solche
ausserordentlichen notlagen in wie die
in der wir uns befinden ist die
ausnahmeregelung der schuldenbremse
da und so sehr sich das wünscht der
staat wird weitere kredite aufnehmen
wenn er damit
zukunftsfähig investiert wird das
vielleicht auch einnahmen generieren die
diese schulden wieder ausgleichen
irgendwann
es gibt wege er mit gedanke für ihren
impuls gruß nach hannover
nicht weit davon im lippischen detmold
olaf kramer ist in der leitung hallo
grüß ich ja guten platz zusammen ja wir
erleben derzeit wie es immer mehr sehr
reiche menschen gibt und das vermögen
immer ungleicher verteilt ist und wir
erleben wie die erhitzung unsere
ökosysteme und die lebensgrundlagen
zerstört schon jetzt bei 13 grad
erwärmung wärmen müssen jetzt zur
kenntnis nehmen dass deutschlands von
einem fruchtbaren und wasser reichen
land sich zu einem hochrisiko standort
gewandelt hat und
wir haben in großen riesige region
unsere nadelwälder verloren die
laubwälder schwer krank und wir bauern
erleben innerhalb von fünf jahren das
vierte dürre jahr was einfach existenz
verstörend ist und daraus resultiert für
mich dass die hilfen radikal
sozialverträglich sein müssen und sie
dürfen die schere zwischen arm und reich
nicht weiter öffnen damit es eine
akzeptanz im volk gibt und wir müssen
radikal klimaverträglich sein weil uns
die erhitzung keine zeit mehr lässt zu
verhindern dass diese wunderbare erde
kein ort zum leben für menschen mehr
sein wird denn das das was wir vor augen
haben und was einfach viel schneller
kommt als
vorhergesehen und bleiben nur noch
wenige jahre und danach ist diese krise
nicht mehr heilbar das ist ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal
der klimakrise das betrifft ja das ist
klare argumente zu hören aber noch die
frage kurz lang schließen was okay ja
aber man kann die kleinere
regierungspartei aus durch und durch
ideologischen gründen jeden ansatz für
problemlösungen bieler beiden wichtigen
probleme mit labortieren ja danke ich
habe eine rückfrage sanieren bauern das
heißt sie sind selbst landwirt ja genau
und ich habe meinen bald verloren und
ich erlebe das meinhof einfach nichts
mehr wert ist weil wir ständig höhere
haben und einfach auf dem grünland jetzt
schon seit sechs wochen nichts mehr
wächst und wählen einen und wir und
tausende andere höfe auch in den
ackerbau gebieten wo die leichten böden
sind ganz brandenburg und so weiter das
emsland sind existenziell bedroht durch
einer klimakrise die offenbar von den
politikern und auch den medien in der
tiefe immer noch nicht begriffen wurde
und das ist einfach schockierend
danke dass ihr den hintergrund gesagt
haben das merkmal auch ihre energie bei
dem thema noch mal verständlicher herbst
alles hängt mit allem zusammen und
jenseits dessen was sie gerade
beschrieben haben ist es ja auch so dass
wir
weil es die klimakrise gibt die
energiekrise heute größer ist wir
bekommen bestimmte rohstoffe nicht mehr
per schiff über den rhein wir haben das
problem dass wir strom nach frankreich
liefern müssen die früher man mit ihren
vielen atomkraftwerken und strom
geliefert haben weil denen das
kühlwasser fehlt und weil sie viele alte
reaktoren haben die sie jetzt im sommer
extrem intensiv warten müssen die hätten
gerne reaktoren der qualität wie wir sie
noch am netz haben dann hätten sie
nämlich weniger probleme an den grenzen
des saarlandes liegt das große
atomkraftwerk cattenom
dort gibt es ausfallzeiten und probleme
die es in diesem umfang in deutschen akw
es nie gegeben hat das heißt alles hängt
immer mit allem irgendwie zusammen und
die klimakrise
befördert halt eben auch noch die
aktuelle energie quer damit ist die
frage von herrn ackermann nicht
beantwortet er ist erst mal die
wertungen wegzug so die gdp so kleine
partei weiß auch kann weil sie es kann
er wird gebraucht ohne die fdp hat diese
koalition keine mehrheit
herr lindner kann das und herr lindner
hat zurzeit schlechte umfragewerte und
er möchte sie verbessern ob das gelingt
da kann man noch mal ein fragezeichen
machen bedanke mich alles gute für sie
groß nach detmold und in kusterdingen
des bacchus ratgeber jetzt bei uns hallo
herr ratgebern
schönen guten tag in die wunde
guten tag sie sind dran und der impuls
ihre frage bitte
wir sind wer nachhaltig also das spricht
wir halten ausschließlich mit holz die
in der produktion anfallen wir haben
unseren fuhrpark jetzt schon auf autos
umgestellt die frage ist entlastungen
sind für uns nicht drin warum wird mit
der gießkanne ausgeteilt und nicht
wirklich bezogen auf den einzelnen
menschen diese verbrecher gegeben welche
form von entlastung hätten sie
persönlich nötig
ich momentan nicht
aber ich rede auch über menschen die zum
beispiel für mich arbeiten die wirklich
am existenzminimum teilweise sind okay
ist eigentlich eine frage nach dieser
sendung die eine offene türen einrennt
denn ihre bedürftigkeit haben wir viel
gesprochen frei ist ja das stimmt ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre frage und ich
bin sagt toll dass sie sich
eben auch als als
unternehmer zu wort melden und eben ihre
situation schildern und das ist
sicherlich ein punkt der der auch in dem
in diesem nächsten entlastungspaket ganz
dringend angegangen werden muss das eben
die kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmer die auch unter diesen
aktuellen energiepreisen leiden unter
der inflation dass die auch gezielter
entlastet werden auch bei denen bei
denen es zumindest notwendig ist ich
finde aber klasse dass sie sagen dass
sie sich schon so anstrengen und und
sehr viel dafür tun um klimaneutral zu
werden das sind ja wichtige richtige
schritte damit wir eben diese große
herausforderung vor der das land steht
auch angehen vielen dank herr ratgeber
also wir stimmen sozusagen ihren ihrer
wahrnehmung und ihrer frage zu gruß nach
kusterdingen und
regine volkmann ist in caputh am telefon
guten tag war weidmann
das klappt nicht hallo ich konnte die ja
jetzt sind sie dran twitter her okay ich
hatte die frage die die umlage die uns
jetzt aufgedrückt wird
die alle die alle betrifft und die zb
rwe und shell gar nicht beanspruchen und
dann soll uns jetzt eine entlastung
durch diese mehrwertsteuer
wieder entlastung bringen also das
erinnert mich stark an diese ganze
benzin problematik da wurde erst in
europa schlagen und 30 sind wurden
wieder runter genommen wurde und als
entlastung verkauft
jeden tag werden neue vorschläge gemacht
bis einzig dieser was leipzig gewonnen
sondern kretschmann denn alles nicht
mehr nachgefragt
ja danke ihnen
ich lasse das einfach mal als bewertung
stehen
gar nicht als frage und gehe dann direkt
weiter nach hamm westfalen zu klaus
hoffmann haben viel über rentnerinnen
und rentner gesprochen herr hoffmann und
das betrifft sie ja
auch erstmal
ich würde gerne wissen wie sich
regierung das vorstellt jede woche
praktisch ein neues paket was der
geschicht ja bloß man mir erstmal nichts
angekommen man den rentnern überhaupt
nicht in den beiden muss ich auch sagen
ich bezahle miete und habe kein haus
oder große grundstück wieder von geredet
wurde das hat mir jeder rentner muss
sich dann erst in die armut getrieben
werden ja dennoch komme er gut in die
armut getrieben werden damit ich zum
sozialamt gehen muss denn dieser
regierung das so weiter macht kann ich
nur hoffen dass die leute wirklich auf
der straße wie danke schön herr hoffmann
danke für die klaren worte nach hamm
frau weniger ja das ist das was ich
vorhin meinte dass die
unterschiedlichkeit bei den rentnern ist
enorm groß und ich würde mir wünschen
dass auch von der regierung dann noch
mal wirklich auch etwas angeboten wird
hilfen da auch für sie kommen ich habe
ein beispiel auch jetzt wenn ich das
noch erzählen darf letzte woche hat mir
nach in ihrer rechnung geschickt ihre
kalkulation gaspreis aus einer
sächsischen kleinstadt
wo sie die gasanlage noch gar nicht
berücksichtigt hatte verdreifachung
kilowattstunde kennen wir alle dann noch
monatlicher grundpreis noch mal 30 euro
drauf und dann hatte sie auf einmal
einen monatlichen abschlag von nicht 90
euro sondern 250 euro zu bezahlen und
ich kann das völlig nachvollziehen was
sie sagen dass sie da wirklich auch
jetzt ernsthafte sorgen haben
prüfen sie alles was möglich ist auch an
hilfen zu bekommen porsche hat das wenn
auch gesagt und ich würde mir wünschen
dass gerade für sie auch da noch
wirklich was in diesen entlastungspaket
an angeboten drin ist weil ich glaube
sonst
werden sie da auch zu unrecht wirklich
in notwehr hofft man danke während wir
sprechen hat traut bottoms hier in der
leitung auch sich bemerkbar gemacht aus
oberursel iv robotern sie haben genau
das gleiche thema wenn ich das richtig
hören
wollen sie noch ihre situation schildern
und ergänzend und
[Musik]
ich mache mir ernsthaft sorgen
irgendwann irgendjemand zu dürftig sind
verlässlich bin völlig allein und ich
habe angst deswegen haben 127 jahre
arbeitet und zum amt gehen das macht im
schnitt future lieber wird zum auto
hinfahren aber
danke
das ist ihre haltung
ist natürlich genau der konflikt aber
sie haben es ja eingangs der sendung
auch gesagt das ist eine haltung die
ganz ganz viele menschen in diesem land
haben das ist ein satz der mir oft
begegnet ich ich ich ich kann nur sagen
sie haben womöglich anspruch darauf das
ist ihr recht dass es nichts wofür sie
sich in irgendeiner weise schämen
müssten also ich kann ihnen nur raten
sich beraten zu lassen und das was ihnen
zusteht sich auch sich auch mit damit
sich auch helfen zu lassen aber das wird
ihnen wahrscheinlich das wird sie
wahrscheinlich überzeugen sie klangen
sehr
klar in diesem punkt es ist ja auch mal
ehrenwert aber gut das ist so offen
ansprechen und ist ganz sicher etwas wo
ja erstmal auch die politik sich klarer
positionieren und drüber sprechen sollte
ein einzelfall das wird man häufiger der
gruß in den taunus danke nochmal und wir
bleiben in der nähe in groß gerau bei
henning magirus guten tag herr marius
jörg schönbohm und auch an herrn kusch
ja ich gehe noch mal auf die erste frage
ein die ein zuschauer gestellt hat das
betrifft die rundfunkgebühren eine bitte
wenn ich jetzt meinen äußerungen
getätigt habe bitte werden sie mich
nicht sofort aus der leitung trinken sie
mich nicht raus der schönbohm das ist
mir vor vier wochen passiert also schon
mal in der sendung war und nicht alle an
der blick auf die uhr nur sagen wir sind
kurz vor dem ende der sendung deshalb
würde ich sagen kurz zwei sätze okay ja
ich wollte das unterstützen die antwort
von der puschner war natürlich fremming
wie immer das heißt wer hat abgelenkt
von dem eigentlichen thema dass jeder
bürger mehr geld in der tasche hätte
wenn die rundfunkgebühren abgeschafft
werden es geht um 8 milliarden euro das
ist der grösste rundfunk der welt und
das muss ein ende haben wenn sie rund 80
prozent der bevölkerung sagt wir wollen
das nicht mehr leisten
und da müssen sie herr schönbohm aber
auch wirklich mal und sie alle hier am
tisch in sich gehen die davon
profitieren wir sind die hart arbeitende
bevölkerung ich bin architekt ich bin
freiberufler
ich habe drei kinder die im studium sind
ich weiß jetzt im herbst auch nicht mehr
wie ich alles finanzieren soll und wenn
ich ihre sendung anschauen sie war
jahrelang ganz okay aber auch in den
letzten monaten ist das training
training training also die kunst des
weglassens man aber dass man sich ja
gerade auch sie fremden ja gerade auch
nicht diskutieren mit ihnen gern gern
über natürlich rechtlichen rundfunks
machen wir in unserer zeit und ständig
damit dass er als eigentlich nicht das
thema aus thema ist ja wie die leute
finden das
mit blick auf die originale ich dauer
ansteigen leider nein herr matthäus
ich bedanke mich sie haben es
angesprochen das war ja anliegen der
gegenwert dafür sind für die meisten
menschen mehrere stunden am tag radio
fernsehen internet mit angeboten diese
sehr schätzen und die entscheidung über
den rundfunkbeitrag treffen nicht ich
niemand hier im raum den treffen 16
landtage also insofern ist es ein ganz
demokratisches verfahren das vielleicht
noch als information das ist aber dann
auch das ende der sendung anders als
geplant bedanke mich jetzt kommen die
nachrichten einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]